assemble and deploy the Space Telescope
okay we take everything that we've
learned thus far and we apply it that's
what we do so far so so far we've
learned
yes from orbit we can obtain a vision of
space that is undiluted by our planet's
atmosphere stupid Newtonian atmosphere
stupid Newtons here
information will be obtained from an
optical Space Telescope so we're going
to be able to most telescopes are
Optical you must assemble it
oh how long did it take him to build the
James Webb uh so it's it's what it's 10
30 for me now so about six years okay
all right let's we can do it
we can do it in nine watch this this tip
will give me a a reason to live
uh
oh God you have to sit in a chair and
clean it God okay we can do this pair
the crane arms using the ratchet
assemble the telescope attach the
falling components solar panel solar
panel receiver processor
okay there's six parts seven including
the main body okay okay hang on
oh hang on okay there's like a Mario
pipe that goes in the left there's a
Lego head that goes in the right there's
a uh
top and bottom chocolate bar an antenna
and a lens cap yep and a lens cap oh
that's actually just something we take
the lens cap off we have to take the
lenses all the pictures are going to be
dark and we're going to be confused
someone back up here now this
I don't [ __ ] know all righty Lefty
makes the arm open shut
okay wait we'll rock paper scissors
does one of us have to be in a chair and
the other one has to do the controls God
I hope not and I don't know which one I
don't want okay anything that's tethered
wait I should probably actually keep
that tethered down yeah keep that
tethered down
um okay it's gotta be in like those
suitcases right I would imagine while
you're doing that I'm gonna go explore
the rest of the ship and figure out a
way to kill myself
I found a crowbar I found fireworks
who brought these on boards Oh Captain I
was gonna celebrate a job well done
don't explode don't explode
it didn't oh thank God you wished it and
Newton granted you your wish Newton
didn't do [ __ ] I made my own look Newton
be praised Newton be damned to the
seventh circle of hell all right have
fun with your Satan origin Newton
Newton's Hill I'm in the chair
what do I do
ah okay so that's other two chairs right
that's broken oh God there's two chairs
why is the Crowbar tethered do they not
trust us I I really don't know but
that's one of the solar panels that we
need
what we don't need is a bunch of other
crap floating around
okay so I'm assuming that we need to
find a wrench though have you found a
wrench
uh not insofar as I know not in such
words as wrench and find okay pass that
to me I've got it there you go there you
go oh the middle moves
okay yeah
there's no way that stuff is hiding in
these packages right they wouldn't do
that no no no no way no way no way no
way and if there is I hope there's a gun
in it
one can only hope I could shoot you
twice
thanks man me too
all right so we need to find a wrench
right
yeah yes so there's got to be another
container somewhere around here wait how
did you get in the chair oh why why yeah
so those don't work that's what we need
the wrench for I'm gonna go explore
um I oh I hesitate to think it's in any
one of these buckled in things but I
feel like we gotta open one of them
eventually yeah I feel like I didn't see
anything anywhere else oh my God I did
my arms were completely backwards again
for some reason just like I completely
forgot what arm was arm yeah ah okay I'm
gonna untie this oh I think it's
probably in that little white one
oh my God please could I
could I just
oh could I just oh wait wait wait no
it's over here don't untether do not
untether going on Tether oh I was close
to hitting the nuke launch
okay I had the codes I found the socket
wrench okay I got it if only I didn't
have the stupid head I can clip it to my
belt
you can clip it to your belt you can
clip tools to your belt
I I [ __ ] hate
I hate
that was a thing all along yes also I
still can't figure out this moving thing
but
you can Orient yourself if you want no
everywhere I need I need to do up
orientations like standard because this
way if I ever get in a terrible
situation I'll always know how to get
out of it it's just every once in a
while it's like my left right brain will
just stop working and forget
it's like I know and then I know and
then I'm good and then I instantly
forget yep okay but I'm making it's a
lot harder than it looks folks yeah you
try and everyone writing a big old
comment about how oh I blood this game
you know I got it in a few seconds yeah
well shut Up And subscribe leave a like
if you're so smart figure that out
you can't leave a dislike anymore so you
might as well leave one of them yeah huh
interact with the video for once okay
I'm going outside all these [ __ ]
neuteners yeah I bet they believe in
dude
I still believe in gravity just walk on
walls stupid stupid I'm gonna fix this
thing now
crank okay I'm cranking it
uh
uh I think yep
does it have to be aligned oh what I'm
jammed in it yeah I think it's gotta be
aligned okay sit in that seat and see
what it do
God how's the hand of down here I was
busy looking at you
I know I'm very pretty when I do what I
do yeah you're very pretty when you
wrench yeah yeah why are you down there
got him got him Blues
well uh you see I would think that that
would be the right thing
I would believe so you just keep trying
I'm gonna I'm gonna yank it around a
little bit try not to be distracted by
my wrenching
I'm dancing I'm I'm chill okay
it was one yank away okay so what does
this do okay that's left and right and
this is back and forth okay okay let me
get you okay you're jammed up on your
elevator there let me try to get you
what you need oh no it fixed itself no
no stop it's perfect don't ruin it but I
need to put this on you didn't see what
you were doing with the elevator did you
I did not you were making it was perfect
then it fixed itself but now it's super
jammed
sorry excuse me sorry my fat ass gotta
make its way here it's a button yeah no
not that button don't oh God
there's a button ah thanks yes there's a
button appreciate that did you know if
you just press the button yep
so you're like super jammed in here I
gotta yank some stuff out don't press
the button what even is that what do you
mean what is that it's a solar panel oh
that's it's no no I the other one it's
the the head for the end yeah yes yes
and I gotta get this out of here for a
second because that's that dish is in
there
and I can push it from this side
maybe you got it once it's clear give me
the clear okay I'll say clear when it's
clear clear nope oh yeah how do I push
this
how do I push anything no uh no uh there
we go almost oh you can lift man okay I
smashed it clear no uh it's not clear
oh grab the elevator
I might be able to just
if I could just wait I'm pushing it
has a flap on the side there there my
hand might get squished but I think it
might be okay
oh my God push the [ __ ] button
okay you're clear
there you go all right I'll go fix the
other one while we're doing this well
you you sort those two pieces out I'll
get the other one wrenched up you got it
Jimbo turns out some of these pieces
have already left my sphere of influence
we've lost them
hey Sputnik what's up Sputnik
you want to [ __ ] help oh why why is
this this way why has Newton forsaken me
why because you believed in them
it's an equal and opposite reaction I
believe in him therefore he abandons me
but if you don't believe
he's there then you get to be a hero
like me whatever you do do not untether
this telescope
why would I untether the telescope I can
see in your brain that you want to do it
I didn't even know it was a thing now I
see it now it's in my brain thanks now
I'm gonna kill us all oh good for you
you made me do this
oh [ __ ] I'm back
okay welcome back all right do you need
assistance
no all right I am good at [ __ ] things
off stay clamped stupid that's my right
hand oh it is my right oh my god do you
need assistance every time I'm upside
down this is like I uh the solar panel
is gone they [ __ ] did it oh my God
I'm so good hold on well done well done
well done GG let's go uh pog
it's very wobbly oh my God I'm just a
crane arm now I've become one with the
station that's good for you that's so
good for you
oh what a throw thank you while you were
busy playing around I was here
training whoops well you were picking
flowers the little sperm was growing
I don't think sperm's supposed to grow
it was growing just one giga spur what
do you think is in each of my balls
just one
it's not even uh can you uh not cram me
here and push the button again so I can
get around and then put it oh you want
the crane off other times you want it
down make up your mind I never said
anything about the elevator you were
kind of doing it on your own I just
won't point that out Kevin oh you're
talking about balls I understood what
you meant hang on one second captain uh
we will talk about my balls in a mirror
moment you are so in the way you
couldn't possibly be more in the way
or there's no way that I can do this
because you're in the way if I could
drop any more hints I would that you're
in thank you you know communication is
key you can just ask for what you want I
feel like I was pretty explicit about
how in the way you were mind reader okay
all right where are you going I'm trying
to Oh Captain don't yell at me I will
literally murder everybody you'll make
me do it you'll you'll make me take it
why does it keep coming this way take it
just take it
down here take it take it just take it
[ __ ] I don't want it take it move it
that way it's gonna go that way
oh that way
just move it I'm trying tell me this way
go that way hey I did it there okay good
all right I'm going back I'm going back
to my chair no don't push that button do
not push that button yet do not push
that button yet you were thinking about
it weren't you I want
to do not I'm going the wrong way again
do not push that button oh my God I'm
gonna kill if you don't get here in five
seconds
oh oh my God
[Music]
oh I'm fine
hi look at that you're in the way again
okay all right okay
open the elevator
you good I'm good yeah you know how to
say Mom and Dad are fighting and yelling
at each other but you're one of the mom
and dad and you hate it oh my God why is
this being like this why do you think I
want to bring this out here
do you think that do you think I want
that dude
[Music]
okay I feel like I should get out of the
way yes yes okay grab it grab it grab it
grab it grab it grab the thing grab it
grab it not that way no yes there it is
I'm putting it in I'm gonna put it in
oh
no no no no no no no it's okay I'll
block it off
button stop stop okay
good
okay let's just let it go just let it
[ __ ] go go it's going it's in it
right
come up you [ __ ]
okay good job all right I'll go get the
other pieces isn't that it oh there's
one left oh lens cap yeah lens lens
yeah can you get the elevator out of the
way it's uh
ah you and your elevator
okay thank you wow it's in my way
all right you're clear go for it
all right we are doing so good oh so
good
oh
what what
oh we have to do that to unpack it oh
all right I'll go get doing this
and I'll just stay here and be in the
way all right oh okay
what do you think robot friend oh yes
very delightful
do you think we should open the space
hatch should we end it all I can't see
anything
way to zoom out or something is I'll
just come okay cool what the hell was
the point of the Crowbar I'm thinking
that there never was a point to the
Crowbar and we just for some reason
think that the Crowbar is important in
fact it's actually yeah it's never been
important
Clank got that
oh
oh hey no no no no no no no
oh my God space [ __ ] sucks so does
this willingly space sucks
oh come on
oh
come on every time I get to a wall there
I accidentally push away from it
huh
oh
you got it I got it I keep wanting to go
in sideways oh my [ __ ] my God I wanna
die
my crave death it needs a crowbar oh we
bring it together tethered it's tethered
it's tethered it's fine okay we gotta go
back we gotta go back okay we gotta go
back we gotta go ahead
we got it we can't go
I'm trying
hey
[ __ ]
you're gonna be stuck there
trying to be stuck here than anywhere
oh my God stop boxing me in I'm going
for it I'm pulling the box back so it
doesn't box again this is what the box
wants
oh my God what hand is what
there you go there you go there you go
solid solid as a rock I know solid as a
Johnson
Johnson
Dwayne
oh this is like oh this is like giving
birth am I right everyone who's given
birth is just like it we now know your
pain
yes she goes that's our baby right
that's how birds Works hold your head
held high let go
I'm guiding the sperm all right
[Music]
not that way there's no room it won't
fit trust me I know about that
yeah okay
uh is it getting damaged uh
be very careful that's fine no there's
no [ __ ] way they would add a damage
factor to this game my God they want
people to uninstall it and get the money
back my guy my bro
what hand is what right now oh my God oh
my God I keep getting them backwards
every
single time when I'm upside down my
brain flips
one-handed this is no God okay because
my problem is his left hand is the right
button that's the problem I don't mirror
people okay I don't do mirroring
is the right button left is left no his
left hand is my right button
so if I was him the way he's facing it
messes with my brain I get you you're
thinking first person perspective yes
that's how I think gotcha so like that's
why whenever someone says like you got a
piece of food on your mouth I go to
where they Point not the mirrored
version see and if you live life in a
true mirror ah yeah sure maybe yes
huh it's just really messing with me I
wonder if there's a way just to invert
the controls because that would probably
help me you probably can
can you oh God don't [ __ ] away careful
be careful it's getting damaged good
then the item will come out of it no
that's not probably how that works oh
sorry I dragged you I'll push you
go are we wait are we going up with this
or yeah we got to go up oh boxes all
right I'm gonna grab the thing and bring
it down a little bit oh or not oh watch
your socket wrench oh there we go there
we go there we go I don't fit how does
that help that don't fit what are you
trying to do
I was trying to just see if it would go
left why would it go left
hello I don't want to unbox things we
have to unbox things where else are we
gonna take it
no I'll grab it I'll pull it down and
then you go up and undo that okay well
wait before I get until I get it down
first I am not pressing anything okay
okay okay I'm chilling you're knocking
me around with a box okay hold on hold
on here we go okay go no no no I want to
pull down there we go
oh
okay okay okay okay okay okay and you're
probably gonna have to move them into
that side room
don't grab the [ __ ] thing oh good
luck
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna leave that for
now I'll just go into any room please
why is it why this way
I
hear oh God I'll guide you
there we go that's fine that'll do
that's enough that is shockingly enough
okay
yeah just get that get that out of there
yeah yeah get the [ __ ] out of here
probably believes that Newton uh you
know I would honestly pray to Newton
right now if it could give me any
salvation from this
I'm waiting for the Grava to wrap shirt
to come and claim me
to reverse gravity up into the heavens
I'll believe in a flat Earth if it gets
me through this any quicker yeah
I'm really slamming it it's okay I think
it's I think it's just an aesthetic
thing I don't think you're actually
damaging it if this resets the level I
am going to throw my computer out of the
window I'm gonna throw up okay grab it
grab it grab it grab it oh God okay
you're not at the point to grab it I see
okay you should say to grab it right as
I'm getting out of your way okay
okay which hand is which I gotta think
about this it says right it's my left
left yes okay
oh wait that's [ __ ] backwards what am
I doing okay we're almost there oh no no
no yes yes
okay grab it
[ __ ] sake
okay I'm gonna let go of the wrong hand
but that's okay yes I am a human nurse
wedge and okay I'm gonna send it
okay there we go crowbar do your thing
crowbar do a thing do a crowbar yeah go
crowbar go
all you got to do is grab it use
headbutt you did it you're doing it it
came out well don't pull it out put it
in I didn't know it could come out
it magnetizes in on its own there you go
you got it okay fulcrum fulcrum fulcrum
fulcrum
it's probably another one of those
Newton [ __ ] theories come on what am
I doing wrong you're doing it you're
doing it I need I need a solid anchor
wait yes yes I'm gonna tether this end
to it
yes yes
yes
yes do it I'm trying it's farther away
now than it once was
oh I was tethered it was tethered it was
tethered it was Tethered on oh we got it
we did it
we did it I know you're trapped ah it's
okay it's back in the box now
what I feel like it went back in and the
lid just like slammed right back into
place level failed oh [ __ ]
oh look at this nice nice let me try to
grab the box I got the box get it out of
the box and don't get in the Box Captain
come on now stop stop
playing
okay
grab it Captain grab it tap and grab it
go get it
the [ __ ] trying
Captain's going down
I'm gonna I'm gonna cry God and that's
clearly the wrong answer here I'll get
this out of the way no I won't okay
okay okay
if it would just
being a big
oh my God what do I what do I do what do
I what do I do you got it you got it
Captain you got it you're doing it and
you're doing it so well I'm starfishing
I'm starfishing
that's great that's great I'm here too
it's coming to you sis I'm here
for everything this is what they call
the slammed up
I'm too fat to fit in and it but I'm
gonna I let go the wrong hand because I
forgot because I'm upside down
where are you going Captain well at
least we have it hang on I got this no I
don't
know well at least that's like blocked
off you can't go out it'll be upside
down ever Captain I just can't my body
can't handle it I'm going for it
there it goes swimming swim it swim it
letting it ride
okay oh yeah I got this
okay usually when you kick off of things
it kind of like actually moves you
yeah usually but usually [ __ ] this okay
okay
it's here at least oh my God I'm gonna
cry
oh don't touch it don't touch it don't
touch it oh my God oh my God I'm gonna
cry just think backwards I can't I can't
okay no no no no no no no why would you
do that why would you push the button
now why would you do it okay okay okay
you're good you're good you're good what
do you mean I'm good grab it pull it
push it somewhere I'm gonna hit the
button don't hit the button why would
you hit the button my head is in the way
okay okay I got it hit the button again
it's my head my stupid [ __ ] head okay
okay I let go now if only it would stop
being wedged
hello
get
okay now you push it in pushing it push
it push it push it and it's pushed and
it's pushed okay okay and I'm out okay
push it again in the chair get in the
chair get in the chair you can do
everything from the chair
no we need the lens cap we can take it
off in there we can take it off in there
we got two chairs where are you going
okay
all right it's taking a little trip
I'm in a chair really wish
I really wish it
okay
all right I have no idea how to use this
thing okay so left stick is around I got
it actually it's it's surprisingly wow
this is intuitive huh who'da thought
yeah hold on Lefty is let go okay there
you go
hoop and if you get in here it just kind
of magnetizes yeah yeah oh yeah
you just wanted me to have it huh yeah
yeah so you could have a chance oh oh oh
oh oh
oh
it's okay it's okay it'll work when you
move it you gotta keep clamped ah I'm
clamped all right just Just Let It Go
just Let It Go it'll go in it'll go in
Just Let It Go just Let It Go I don't
let it go I don't believe I don't
believe okay now and now actually let it
go though okay there you go a lens cap
now lens caps cap lens cap okay
you got it you got it oh beautiful boy
welcome to the world
our baby
we did that we did that we made that the
big cheese and the sperm wow
oh no no what no no no we were done we
what
I gotta open the door
to throw yourself out of it
no I gotta untether and then
there he goes okay now there you go we
don't gotta go out there
no okay you just gotta push him out okay
use use the chair I'm in the chair go
baby girl this is how telescopes are
launched uh yeah hey there's a Sputnik
we were supposed to do that right yeah
oh God
oh thank God
it'll be fine I'm sure it's not a good
trajectory
wow what does it see
uh for a combination control I I feel
like a [ __ ] a piece of actual [ __ ]
floating through a sewer system I'm
trying to navigate this game yeah it's
so funny that like at the point when I'm
finally starting to get a hang of it is
when I'm gonna delete this game forever
and never Play It Again
which I'm gonna do after you press that
button
great game well made
oh no wait for the steam review it is
actually a good game my anger is
independent I want to go home I don't
want to do it I want to go home it's
going to get harder it's gonna get
harder it's going to get much harder
it's gonna get harder all right let's
take a look let's just see what it is
let's see what it is
uh attach the thrusters to the mod no no
no I'm no not even no I'm leaving I'm
leaving thanks for watching guys
subscribe like bye subscribe like bye
[Music]
oh